[Musique]
dans ces champs à la queue de chemin les
abeilles butin doucement pendant que
Claude l'apicultrice récolte le miel
d'un de ces trois ruchers
alors ici ça va être le miel le miel des
champs le miel de la forêt parce qu'on
est toussé dans la forêt sur lequel
c'est le miel des champs parce que si on
prend le rayon de 3 km autour des
ruchers ici c'est une bonne proportion
de champ versus de forêt
qu'il proviennent des champs de la forêt
ou du Marais le miel produit ici sera
brut au niveau du rucher on a l'image de
l'environnement même à l'intérieur du
Richer et si je me déplace un peu c'est
sûr que on tombe pas dans des fleurs
complètement différentes mais on peut
tomber dans des variations différentes
et c'est là la nuance qu'on peut
retrouver dans les arômes subtils du
miel brut
le miel brut est au miel qui lors de sa
transformation ne subit aucune chaleur
la portion transformation qui implique
la chaleur comme la plupart c'est la
façon de faire je dirais nord-américaine
enlève une bonne partie des arômes qui
sont si fragiles à la chaleur donc ces
arômes là disparaissent et sont
transformés par un goût c'est un goût
standard de miel mais si on veut aller
un petit peu plus loin dans la
découverte c'est là que le miel brut
entre en jeu
une fois à la miellerie le miel est
conditionné pour diminuer son taux
d'humidité puis il faut désoperculer
c’est-à-dire enlever la couche de cire
qui retient le miel une première étape
sans chaleur en utilisant une fourchette
au lieu d'un couteau chauffant le miel
brute n'a pas d'appellation officielle
ni au Canada ni ailleurs dans le monde
le miel brut en fait c'est une mention
donc il y a pas de côté légal selon
l'Agence canadienne d'inspection des
aliments le miel brut ne doit pas être
filtré et ne doit pas être issu d'un
chauffage quelconque dans le processus
de transformation
extrait ainsi le miel est alors tamisé
placé dans des cuves puis rapidement
couler en pot cette étape si il est
vraiment encore à l'étape liquide c'est
dans sa phase liquide comme il était
dans la rue
ailleurs dans une production
industrielle par exemple on peut
chauffer le miel à toutes les étapes de
la transformation et même dans le pot
pour le garder liquide entre autres un
miel trop chauffé peut perdre ses
enzymes et ne plus rencontrer les normes
d'appellations la chaleur ça diminue la
viscosité du miel donc est plus
facilement malléable plus facilement on
le travaille mieux on travaille plus
rapidement aussi et ça fait en sorte
évidemment que ça diminue les coûts
[Musique]
ça ajoute aussi la pasteurisation en
faisant la pasteurisation pour les
sports de botulisme on élimine aussi
entre autres toutes les nucléés de sucre
les plus gros morceaux de sucre qui
pourraient créer la cristallisation plus
rapide donc en pasteurisant on garde le
miel plus liquide longtemps
[Musique]
alors que le miel brut passe de la phase
liquide à la cristallisation selon
différents facteurs une fois la récolte
effectuée il faut tout de suite le
mettre en pause sinon il va cristalliser
dans les cuves et là c'est fini
ça serait pas très le mettre à cuillère
dans le pot c'est la source botanique et
le facteur numéro 1 si on veut et selon
les différentes sources florales on peut
avoir une cristallisation plus ou moins
dur avec des fins ou des gros cristaux
c'est une cristallisation qui reste
crémeuse quand même qui est agréable
quand on dit le miel va cristalliser le
consommateur est réticent parce que ils
pensent au miel que durcit dans notre
armoire mais un miel brut
c'est généralement très agréable en
bouche
que les deux autres
dans un pot de miel à l'épicerie la
différence au niveau alimentaire par les
arômes je dirais c'est que un miel brut
garde pratiquement tous ces enzymes
qu'est-ce qui est intéressant c'est que
chaque apiculteur fait un miel brut
différent et même j'irai plus loin
chaque ruche mais elle brut différent
[Musique]
ça donne un bel environnement pour nous
aider
le chef du manoir au V propose sur sa
table un miel brute
représenter le terroir puis qui donc qui
représente le mieux le terroir que les
abeilles brutent en plus c'est le
meilleur exemple je me bats pour que
tous les propriétés du miel soit encore
dans l'assiette des gens si toi tu le
fais chauffer tu détruises que les
abeilles ont fait donc tu le détruises
que moi j'ai envie de faire Jérôme
Dubois et sommelier et apiculteur c'est
lui qui a fait découvrir le miel brut au
chef quand il cristallise il devient
beaucoup plus jaune alors que si vous le
rendez liquide et chauffez la couleur va
commencer à devenir légèrement brune et
là ça veut dire au moins qu'une partie
des arômes définitivement les a perdu
mais on voit que comme une texture qui
une journée puis ça va être un beau bloc
de miel il y a pas un miel qui va
terminer de la même façon en terme de
cristallisation qui se passe sorte de
choses dans le miel on le voit se
transformer c'est absolument magnifique
et ça c'est un monde en soi c'est
vraiment impressionnant c'est
intéressant à connaître
le miel